A 360 degree Panoramic Dome Microwave, and
Air-In Shower technology uses 35% less water
by putting tiny air bubbles inside each droplet
of water.
Vsauce, Kevin here.
This is Mind Blow.
Ghent University in Belgium has developed
a contact lens that displays text.
The transparent lens can modulate the transmitted
light using LCD technology, and the image
is visible to other people- not the wearer.
But, they are currently researching ways to
display text to the person wearing the lens
and hope to create a way for road directions,
text messages, and emails to be on your eyes
within five years.
DARPA is developing a foam to help wounded
soldiers and mitigate damage from internal
hemorrhaging.
The Wound Stasis Technology is designed to
be administered on the battlefield and works
with two liquid phases, injected internally,
that mix to become foam which molds around
the organs, compressing internal wounds until
the patient can be safely transported to a
surgeon, who the easily removes the foam and
treats the injury.
Kenshiro is a humanoid robot that copies your
muscles and bones.
It's the closest to a human form so far and
mimics the body of the average japanese 12-year-old
male with the same weight ratios.
It has 160 pulley-like muscles, does squats,
and features aluminum bones.
Newly discovered loris?
Check.
Brand new species?
Extremely cute?
Check.
Venomous teeth?
CHECK.
GravityLight is an alternative to kerosene
lamps that harnesses the power of gravity.
The LED lanterns cost less than $10 to buy
with no running costs, and the 3 seconds it
takes to lift the weight made up of a bag
filled with rocks or dirt powers the light
for half an hour.
It has no batteries, is specifically for third
world countries without reliable access to
mains electricity, and you can find out more
over at their website.
University of Bath researchers are claiming
that vector-based video will lead to the death
of the pixel within the next five years.
Digital pictures are made up of a rectangular
grid of colored cells or pixels.
The smaller and closer together, the higher
the quality and amount of data that needs
to be compressed.
But, vectors present contoured colors presenting
the highest visual quality without a bunch
of pixels needing to be compressed, and they
say this will revolutionize the way visual
media is produced.
"Yo, you got Sneaker Speakers?
Yeah, alright..."
Neuroscientists and software engineers at
the University of Waterloo in Canada have
built the most complex artificial brain ever.
Spaun isn't just a super computer- it mimics
the structure of a real brain, and has 2.5
million simulated neurons constructed to pattern
the brain's cranial subsystems.
It also has a digital eye for visual input,
a robot arm to draw responses, and can pass
very basic IQ tests.
Finally, Further Up Yonder is a time-lapse
from the International Space Station put together
by Giacomo Sardelli.
I'm gonna leave you with a radar sequence
of an asteroid that's over 4 million miles
away from Earth and, as always, thanks for
watching.